sous le soleil les manches de chemise
relever face au jardin partagé le
secrétaire d'état est venu distribuer
les bons points pour ce déplacement
la ville de jouy en josas fait figure
d'exemple sur les problématiques
environnementales et dans sa
collaboration avec l'état un partenariat
qui a permis notamment le financement de
plusieurs projets comme la rénovation
énergétique d'un groupe scolaire pour
près de 400000 euros
voyez ce qui est fait sur la lutte
contre le gaspillage alimentaire dans
les écoles dans les collèges moi c'est
quelque chose qui me tient extrêmement à
coeur les politiques sur l'écomobilité
sur la nouvelle manière de se déplacer
en ville et sur les jardins partagés
bref ici ou lis une véritable
laboratoire vitrine de toutes les bonnes
pratiques qu'on a envie de voir
pour une ville durable dans le pays
demain être d'ici 40 ans jouy en josas
ambitionne d'être autonome en énergie
pour y parvenir la ville agit sur la
consommation des bâtiments les
circulations douces ou encore le
traitement des déchets une démarche
éco-responsable dont bénéficieront
principalement les nouvelles générations
c'est vital pour nos enfants et j'étais
très content aujourd'hui d'avoir des des
petits conseillers municipaux tout
conseil municipal des jeunes
ce sont eux qui vont hériter de la
politique qu'on lance aujourd'hui et les
résultats se sont heureux qu'il ait
vivront donc il est capital pour nos
enfants et petits-enfants d'engager
cette politique avec beaucoup de
détermination
le 17 juillet prochain l'état et les
collectivités pourront une nouvelle fois
faire étalage de leur bonne entente
environnementales lors de la conférence
des territoires prévu au sénat d'autres
sujets comme l'exonération de la taxe
d'habitation pour 80% des ménages
risquent de vite mettre à mal cette
complicité